the division gets compared to destiny a
lot and here's another example you can
exploit a boss for a bunch of rare gear
sounds a bit like Destiny's loot caves
right but it won't be around for much
longer Ubisoft is patching it Tuesday
March twenty seconds the exploit works
like this near the autumns hope safe
house there's a level 30 boss called
bullet King take him out but leave his
minions alive he'll drop some Phoenix
credits and purple gear head back to the
safe house and bullet king will respawn
you can take him down repeatedly for as
much gear as you want but this exploit
will only be around for another day so
make use of it while you can changes are
also coming to the dark zone you can't
teleport within the area but you will be
able to teleport to a specific
checkpoint from outside you'll be able
to heal neutral players too that should
brighten things up a bit the divisions
next update is coming Tuesday March
twenty second after a three-hour
maintenance period so if you want to
farm the bullet King you better get on
it now the rest of you can enjoy the new
tweaks to the dark zone and for all the
other division news you're craving keep
it locked at gamespot